In Hollywood, you're only ever as good as
your last film.
Even if you've been churning out hits for
years on end, all it takes is one awful movie
to take you down a peg.
Here's a look at some awful films that put
an end to an actor's hot streak.
Serena
When Jennifer Lawrence stumbled up to the
podium to collect her Best Actress Oscar for
2012's Silver Linings Playbook, she was already
several films into a hot streak.
She'd turned in an impressive performance
in 2010's Winter's Bone and made her first
appearances in the Hunger Games and X-Men
franchises after that, which collectively
brought in over half a billion dollars.
She got her third Oscar nomination for her
scene-stealing role in American Hustle in
2013 and continued to make the whole blockbuster
thing look easy the following year with Mockingjay:
Part 1.
"Like I said, I know exactly what I have to
do." (Hopefully it's stop starring in X-Men movies)
Unfortunately, her streak ended in tame fashion
in 2014 with the universally panned Serena,
which was rejected by audiences, critics,
and even film distributors.
After a very limited domestic release which
netted under $200,000, Serena disappeared.
Despite an Academy nod for Joy, the final
Hunger Games film turned out to be the lowest-earning
of the lot, and Lawrence's pull has wavered
ever since.
The Great Wall
American movie studios have known for a while
that China's box office has been growing exponentially,
and some have attempted to take advantage
of the Chinese market by altering their movies
to cater to overseas sensibilities.
Others have sought co-productions with Chinese
studios, which is how Matt Damon's The Great
Wall came to be.
Legendary teamed up with the China Film Group
for what turned out to be an epic disappointment,
grossing $45 million stateside.
Director Zhang Yimou brought plenty of his
famed visual flair to the movie, but it was
critically trashed, both in the U.S. and in
China.
The critical reaction wasn't good for Damon,
who had been on a real hot streak with roles
in Interstellar and The Martian, as well as
a producer credit on Manchester By The Sea.
Things haven't exactly been going great for
Damon since.
He saw out 2017 with Suburbicon and Downsizing,
two bizarre comedies that premiered to mixed
reviews at best.
The Ladykillers
Not many actors can claim to have experienced
a hot streak as long as the one Tom Hanks
enjoyed for the better part of 15 years.
From the early 1990s to the midpoint of the
2000s, Hanks was a guaranteed draw at the
box office, with his movies rarely pulling
in less than $100 million.
In that space of time, he starred in such
critically acclaimed hits as Philadelphia,
Forrest Gump, Apollo 13, Saving Private Ryan
and many, many more.
"Somebody later told me it gave people hope.
Nah.
Nah, I don't know anything about that."
It had to happen sometime, but when Hanks'
bubble did eventually burst, it was unexpected.
Nobody saw his hot streak coming to an end
with The Ladykillers.
The idea of Hanks collaborating with the Coen
brothers on this 2004 remake of a British
classic seemed like a surefire recipe for
success.
That wasn't the case, however: The movie barely
recouped its $35 million budget in the domestic
box office and was panned by many of the industry's
top critics.
The Monuments Men
He hasn't been able to hit that $100 million
mark quite as often as Tom Hanks, but George
Clooney is also known to bring in the big
bucks on occasion.
He generated major bank fronting Steven Soderbergh's
popular and highly profitable Ocean's movies,
and his starring role in the critically-panned
1997 Batman and Robin still managed to bring
in a cool $238 million.
In the late 2000s Clooney was undeniably A-list,
but in 2014 his career took a severe nosedive.
Clooney co-wrote, produced, directed and starred
in World War Two caper The Monuments Men,
a story about a rag-tag platoon sent into
Nazi Germany to retrieve stolen works of art.
Despite an all-star cast that included Matt
Damon, Bill Murray, and John Goodman, the
movie bombed in theaters and took a licking
from the critics.
Worse, because Clooney was so involved in
the movie's production, there were few other
people to blame besides the former Batman.
Free State of Jones
Matthew McConaughey's career is a tale told
in two acts.
After years of depending on his looks and
charm to pay the bills with rom-com after
forgettable rom-com, he decided to start acting
again, and Hollywood welcomed him back with
open arms.
Dubbed the "McConaissance" at the time, McConaughey's
turnaround can be traced back to 2011's The
Lincoln Lawyer, which scored highly with critics.
Between his 2014 Best Actor win for Dallas
Buyers Club and his scene-stealing performances
in The Wolf of Wall Street and Interstellar,
McConaughey seemed unstoppable.
Unfortunately, you can't keep making good
choices forever, and McConaughey's 2016 Free
State of Jones was definitely not a good one.
The Civil War drama only managed to claw back
half of its $50 million budget, and the majority
of critics were unimpressed.
Worse, his starring turn in 2017's The Dark
Tower was similarly disliked, spelling the
end of McConaughey's box office domination.
"No matter who crosses the finish line first,
the universe will die out eventually.
Death always wins." (Except when it comes to bad movie adaptations of great books.)
King Arthur: Legend of the Sword
In 2002, Charlie Hunnam starred as Nicholas
Nickleby in a critically acclaimed adaptation
of the classic Dickens novel and then showed
his darker side in 2005's Green Street Hooligans.
Later appearances in Children of Men, Sons
of Anarchy, and Pacific Rim built Hunnam into
a star to watch.
Hunnam followed up the Guillermo del Toro
blockbuster with another del Toro movie, Crimson
Peak, and later, the critically lauded Lost
City of Z.
Unfortunately, his luck was about to run out.
With Hunnam as the face and director Guy Ritchie
at the helm, King Arthur: Legend of the Sword
was supposed to be the start of new franchise
based on the legendary character.
Those plans were hastily scrapped after the
box office numbers spelled disaster.
Warner Bros. signed off on a $175 million
budget, but the film made less than $40 million
domestically.
It looks like in this case, Hunnam wasn't
quite worthy to take the sword from the stone.
"Anyone can pull it once it's been pulled."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!